[Applause]
[Music]
what if Apollo Creed didn't die in rocky
4 this is fan scription
a lifelong rocky fan I grew up watching
the 1976 original through 1990s rocky 5
when rumors of a rocky 6 started to get
thrown around in the early 2000s I was
so excited I even rushed out to buy the
first three issues of sylvester stallone
short-lived lifestyle magazines sly
because they had excerpts from the new
movie script within their pages this
franchise is in my blood I would not be
the same person I am today without these
films being ingrained into my psyche
from eight years old on as time has gone
by and I've gotten older my love and
appreciation for this series has not
waned in the slightest it may be higher
than ever with the recent Creed films
once again bringing in the rocky
universe new life but even when I was
younger the fourth installment in the
franchise stuck out to me it wasn't at
all like the previous three or it's much
reviled direct sequel I like to call it
the rogue rocky movie because of how
totally different it is robots a synth
musical score rocky single-handedly
ending the Cold War yeah this one was
pretty far removed from the simplistic
charm of the first film a friend of mine
once described it as having all the
shine of a great movie if you look at it
from the outside it's this
larger-than-life epic but on the inside
it's empty there's not much to it
revenge robots and Russia that's what
many people take away from rocky 4 and
the over-the-top
80s nosov its presentation to this day
it's still the highest grossing film in
the franchise and was one of 1985's
biggest theatrical releases needless to
say it connected with its audience but
I've always thought there is a really
good story
beneath the dated cultural disposition
and awkward jokes in my opinion the
biggest sin this movie committed was
killing Apollo Creed
[Music]
by the end of rocky 3 Apollo was
becoming a complete character he had
gotten ample time to develop as the
antagonist of the first two movies but
in the second sequel his willingness to
help train rocky in his championship
rematch with clubber Lang had taken the
former champ in a bold new direction
becoming an allied to his old rival
proved to be a popular turn while his
motivation to help rocky get the title
back wasn't 100% selfless we saw a side
to Apollo that endeared him to many once
enemies rocky and Apollo had now grown
to be very close friends who knew each
other in ways only they could understand
by the time rocky 4 rolled around both
men weren't as young as they used to be
Rocky seemed okay with accepting this
but Apollo wasn't so quick to admit that
fact and probably the best character
seen in the movie we see the
stubbornness that would eventually
become Apollo's downfall and without
some some challenge fact in the water
you may as well be danced out this is
the basis of everything
Apollo's resistance to change his pride
getting in the way of his common sense
it's not the first time we saw that in
this series remember in the last round
of the fight in rocky 2 all Apollo had
to do was stay away from Balboa and he
would have retained his title this time
however the consequence was losing more
than just his championship now I've
always felt that Apollo's death in rocky
4 was cheap they wasted a great
character just to give Rocky the
motivation to avenge him in a hostile
Soviet environment there still needs to
be consequences for Apollo's actions but
death is the easy way out here Apollo
rather dying than living with the shame
of losing to Drago and the fashion he
did is a cautionary outcome but most of
us don't die when we fail we have to
learn how to live with it and move on
something Apollo admits that he couldn't
even do in his loss too rocky in the
second film
one second you beat me by one second one
second that's very hard for a man of my
intelligence the hell is it but didn't
you say up that bitch you learned how to
live with it I like moving forward no
matter what is pretty much the basis of
the Rocky movies in general seeing that
moral apply to a guy who's portrayed to
be the proudest among us it's where we
can see a much more interesting story
play out our changes start in the first
fight with Drago up until this point
everything happens as it does in the
original version well maybe a little
less robot at this point Apollo's
confidence is at an all-time high at the
same time it's obvious he's going
through a sort of midlife crisis in the
Rocky movies timeline it would be around
this point that he cheats on his wife
and conceives Adonis while in the state
of mind that he was shown to be in
that's not a stretch to imagine Apollo
gets pummeled in that first round and we
still have him worn rocky to not stop
the fight in this second round is where
we diverge Apollo is once again
relentlessly attacked by Drago
rocky however is more ready to stop the
fight and save his friend then see pride
become his demands
Apollo is violently beaten to the point
of unconsciousness the ropes are the
only thing holding him up however before
Drago delivers the final blow
rocky actually throws in the towel
prompting the ref to aggressively stop
Drago rocky Paulie and Tony also rush
into the ring to keep Drago away the
fight is then awarded to the Siberian
Bowl by TKO Apollo collapses in a heap
and the ending of this scene plays out
just about the same way
rocky holding Apollo's bloodied body as
he exchanges hateful stares with the
Russian instead of dissolving - Apollo's
funeral we fade to a hospital room where
Apollo's wife Marianne is talking with a
doctor Tony and Paulie are sitting
outside looking emotionally drained and
peering into the room through a window
are rocky and Adrian it is revealed to
be several days removed from the fight
and while Apollo has made it out of the
woods in terms of the fight for his life
we find out that he has been partially
paralyzed due to brain trauma affecting
some of Apollo's motor skills
the doctors doubt he'll ever walk again
Marianne steps out and says that Apollo
is awake
lucky can go in to see him rocky
cautiously enters the room and stands
next to Apollo's bed it's not a pretty
sight the once proud champion has been
reduced to a shell of his former self
bitter and angry
Apollo lashes out at rocky with all the
venom he can muster for throwing in the
towel Balboa is baffled by this reaction
he had saved his friend's life but
according to Apollo he'd rather be dead
than live as an invalid their
confrontation ends with Apollo kicking
rocky out of the room heartbroken rocky
obliges all the frustrations sadness and
anger that rocky has been feeling is
then directed straight and Apollo's
assailant Ivan Drago as he's alluded to
but not directly shown in the actual
movie Rocky demands a fight with Drago
the boxing commission refuses to
sanction the match and to get his hands
on the Russian Rocky gives up his title
this is focused on a little more it
should have been a bigger deal and
reflective of the fact that boxing
officials in the US don't trust rocky
not to get seriously hurt in this match
rocky pursues the fight anyway and it's
announced for December 25th in the
Soviet Union Adrian is of course opposed
to rocky fighting and we still get that
great scene in their house where she
admits she doesn't believe her husband
is up to this particular challenge in an
exchange reminiscent of a few
conversations in the first two films
tony has a talk with his former pupil to
tell him he's traveling with Rocky to
Russia to help him train it's been
several months since the fight with
Drago and while Apollo has recovered
much more than his doctors previously
thought it is confirmed he will be
permanently paralyzed from the waist
down rocky and Apollo haven't spoken in
months but Tony knows rocky is doing all
of this for his friend he urges Apollo -
once again Apollo stubborn as ever
remained silent as Tony leaves the room
now the deck is stacked against rocky
even more than before
boxing officials don't believe in him
his wife doesn't believe in him and even
Apollo doesn't seem to believe in him
the only person rocky can have a true
heart-to-heart with is his son that
scene with them before he leaves
absolutely stays in and means much more
now
his son's innocence and faith in his
father gives the elder Balboa a small
boost and it's one he sorely needed Tony
and Pauly are the only ones who travel
with rocky to Russia and everything from
their arrival to the first training
montage pretty much stays the same the
only slight alteration would be in the
scene with rocky and Tony where his
trainer reminds him that while Apollo is
headstrong he knows deep down he
appreciates what rocky is doing for him
and like it or not he'll still be the
one the one that's gonna keep his spirit
alive you're the one after the first
training montage Adrian is still shown
to have arrived in Russia and the couple
embraces accept here she says she's not
alone
rocky notices a van pull up to the house
and out of it emerges Apollo Creed in a
wheelchair when they notice each other
the rivals turned friends share a heavy
complicated look cut to a scene with
just Apollo and rocky in the bar this is
where the heart of the movie takes
center stage after Apollo answers a few
questions about his physical well-being
he apologizes to Rocky and thanks him
for likely saving his life this is
something completely new for the Creed
character and it would be fitting to see
Apollo is always the consistently
confident and obstinate personality but
we see him grow from rocky to to rocky 3
and now we can see him faced with the
biggest challenge of his life in rocky 4
how does a man whose identity and
self-image that were built almost
exclusively on his physical ability deal
with having all of that taken away where
does he go from there
how and in what direction does he move
forward I think those are much more
interesting and thought-provoking
questions than just having him die it
always felt to me like a lazy excuse to
get to the rocky drago grudge match we
can do better
having Apollo set out on a new life
after this chapter is permanently closed
will be far more compelling and
captivating after the friends reconcile
Apollo says he'll be in Rocky's corner
at the fight rocky is a little wary of
that idea but Apollo says he didn't drag
his ass all the way out to the middle of
nowhere to not show his face in Moscow
this means everything to Apollo he wants
to show that even though Drago took
almost everything away from him he
couldn't kill his spirit we then get a
playful callback to a line
from earlier when this is over you know
me style you always think of something
else
[Music]
[Applause]
with Apollo there to help motivate rocky
the Italian stallion is in much better
spirits heading into his fight with a
Siberian Express instead of all anger
and revenge on the mind there's hope
optimism and something different to
prove Apollo entering the arena in
Moscow adds a whole other element to the
proceedings and fight rocky and Apollo
are both now the focus of the Soviet
hatred as they experience the jeers
together when Drago makes his way to the
ring we see glares from all three men
that confront the Soviet national anthem
is especially interesting with Apollo
present from here the focus shifts
completely to Rocky and Drago and the
fight begins as in the original movie
Rocky is dominated by Drago for much of
the first and second round it's here
where things also change a bit we're
gonna have rocky get beaten up a little
more than we saw in the film Drago is
violently attacking early on this
triggers Apollo to grasp for the towel
as it's looking like Rocky is getting
seriously hurt but a POW is quick to
remember something that always set him
and rocky apart right then rocky lands
the shot that busts Drago open and the
fight is no longer a one-sided affair as
this battle goes on similar to the
original we're gonna go ahead and remove
the absurd crowd shift even in this
movie this audience going from cheering
Drago to relentlessly chanting rocky was
over-the-top ridiculous the environment
will still be very much pro-russia and
anti Rocky going into the final round it
is here where we get the final
inspirational push from Apollo he yells
up to his friend that rocky helped him
find another way to live and it took a
while but he sees that now his final
words are a mix of Tony's lines
[Applause]
as it happens in the real rocky for
Balboa goes out there and wins the fight
by a dramatic NACA Apollo they're
celebrating will make the moment even
sweeter and the Soviet crowd doesn't go
crazy for Rocky winning but at this
point he's earned enough respect with
them that he won't get 100% Boop Rocky's
ending speech as cheesy as it is can
still work here because it means more
having Apollo ringside rocky can make
eye contact with him and instead of I he
first says we if we can change
Apollo is clearly affected by Rocky's
words he celebrates outside the ring
with Adrian looking on at the Italian
stallion and his team soak up the moment
the Russian crowd will once again show
rocky respect as hearts on fire kicks in
for the last time and the credits roll
and there we have it what if Apollo
Creed didn't die in rocky for in my
opinion it would have made for a much
stronger movie while continuing to build
Apollo as a remarkably well-rounded
secondary character how do these changes
affect rocky 5
what about Adonis Tommy Gunn and rocky
moving back to the old neighborhood
well I have a ton of ideas for that too
and maybe one day I'll go back to it I
also have to mention that the first
Creed movie largely fixed Apollo's death
for me it made it mean something more in
the legacy of the franchise and I think
Ryan Coogler did an amazing job with
that film this was a fun exercise to see
how rocky 4 could have been improved and
set up interesting alterations to the
sequels so what did you think want to
hear more about the genesis of this idea
and the details I had to leave out of
the video tune into the fan scription
podcast where I talk more about this
what if and dig deeper into why I did
what be on the lookout for more episodes
of fan scription coming soon and thank
you guys so much for watching
[Music]
you